good morning millennials
welcome back to the toast happy Tuesday
and I'm sitting down with a girl who I
choose every day
darling hey girl hey it's Tilly's
trucker hey girl hey I love you I'm so
excited to be back I love hosting with
you and you know what the toaster is
like are obsessed for real real they are
I do feel the love so I will like
receive that compliment you'll receive
it internalize it digest and throw it up
and then eat it again
like a dog which brings me to my apology
Taylor texted me on Sunday I was like oh
hey can you host a toast with me this
week she was like yeah sure I've been
spiraling all weekend I'm so sorry what
I said about Theo like I said Taylor if
you ever apologize to me ever again I'll
slap you in the throat [__] listen I I
felt like I was being haunted by like
animal things all weekend
I was being haunted by the yes by Theo's
ghost you look beautiful I do yeah I
think it's the red red is your color
maybe it's my disgusting hair that I
can't uh bathe in or shower because I
have no hot water I'm so lucky that I
got Taylor to come into Studio on the
week where her and her wife are living
like they live in colonial time I'm only
bathing once a week because their shower
is broken or whatever to be clear I'm
doing body washes yeah I just want to
say the aura and the sort of Aroma
you've brought to the studio I'm kidding
you smell great always yes I really get
no I'm totally kidding no I literally
was like on Instagram all weekend and so
many people I know dogs passed away and
I was hoping that up because I was like
oh my god oh all of a sudden it hit me
like I was like oh over the hill was a
joke but like it's very sensitive it is
so I just wanted to you know some
lessons you have to learn the hard way
to say I'm sorry I forgive you oh no
apology is necessary but it would be
helpful if maybe after this you go and
apologize
did you tell him I think you should
write him a letter I did tell him he was
very upset because he loves you but I
was trying to say we're the same
I don't think he saw it that way okay
well then that's on Theo you're wearing
red today have you heard about this um
I've seen people doing it on Tick Tock
like finding their color ooh it's like
it's like literally a service you pay
for where you get like all these big
swatches of fabric in different colors
and you hold them up to your face yes
that's so dumb I know it's like okay I
can literally go to mood fabrics and
just do this with my phone like for free
you just walk around the store but it's
like these color experts who can tell
you what your color is your color is
definitely red you think so yeah or
green I go back and forth sometimes I
think that maybe I look like a washout
ghost lady like a little bit vampers no
no no no no no no no no no you look
right well we'll see when I look at the
video this might be your spring color I
love a hot pink well so that's what I
learned from these videos that if you go
to your session you get your spring
color and your winter color what are
your colors oh I don't know because I
did I haven't gotten to a session but
like now I'm kind of curious how much is
it
such a good question it should be free
it literally should be free but I'm sure
it's like a hundred dollars or something
I feel worth it right off right up
a good mean girl I think that's a text
gray area I live in the gray I know well
gray might not be your color you know
what it isn't so I slept last night for
the first time with my night guard I got
a night guard yesterday I saw I'm
jealous can I tell you what an
unpleasant experience it was to sleep
with this night guard that's why I don't
use mine it's is it supposed to be like
painfulish in the beginning I mean it I
don't know if it's supposed to be but it
is for me it's like a retainer that
hurts it hurts and there's like this big
like plastic dick in your mouth and I'm
like with my jaw wide open like I get
that and people say like it really works
I think it takes a long time to get used
to it and I like it woke me up I was up
at seven I popped my mat in my mouth you
do yes it's like really welded in there
no but like that's That's How Strong my
tongue is yeah yeah you're a Thruster
that's why your wife loves you
but I uh no I stopped working because I
would wake up in the middle of the night
and be in my hair what it would be in
your hair yeah what would you wear it
for for TMJ I'd wear it for my grinding
so I'm a clencher yeah I mean that that
tracks birds of a feather flock together
yeah and so I went to the dentist
actually I went to Dr Alex who we met in
Lisbon oh my God yeah and they like took
all these hot like really high
definition photos of like my mouth and I
thought it was just the picture of my
mouth I didn't know like my whole face
was gonna be in it so I'm just like
looking like a like a corpse like and
then they put them up on the TV like to
analyze my teeth I'm like who the [__]
is that but what I realized it's like I
clench more on my right I guess I have
like a muscle when I saw the picture
like my cheeks are not symmetrical I got
this big old like jowl on my right side
and like this almost dimple because I'm
clenching so I'm changing the structure
you're a [__] do you really see it like
look look literally look literally I
haven't done it yet ready look
what am I looking for okay like a more
protruding you have a dimple on this
side right and that's like from like my
I've created a dimple because I'm
working my muscle so hard genius you see
that's so nice I mean the truth you're
just walking on no I'm not because you
don't want to offend me like no I'm not
no here's the thing so my really good
family friends our dentist back home
where I grew up and they're like
fantastic and the last time I saw them
which was years ago I stopped going to
them because I did not like what I heard
yeah and also I can't like I I'm an
adult I have to go to the dentist where
I live yeah no also just like the
dentist oh it is Criminal like dentists
should be in jail so she pulled me aside
and she had like tears in her eyes
because she's like my aunt and she was
like Taylor you have to get all your
teeth pulled what get veneers do you
like veneers no do I look like I have no
you move nice to you you see my yellow
Ute yeah you got like a little yellow
one down there but your teeth are very
nice it's a dead one by the way see how
I don't okay look at my teeth see how
this has no like companion yeah it's
just a little lone tooth yeah I had
overcrowding when I was little so they
yanked one of them out so I just have
one little loan tooth and it's yellow
not because she's decrepit and
disgusting it's because she has no
nerves
neither do you you got no nerve
wait that's like crazy I just [__]
hate going to the dentist like it's me
too I feel like my experience yesterday
was as positive as it could have been
they got me in and out I didn't have
cavities or anything but like my God I
just hate going to the dentist me too I
know I have to get a mouth guard I have
to get all new teeth I have to do
everything and like I also haven't been
to the physician for like a checkup like
probably in six years let's go together
and that's because like I just know
they're gonna be like [__] you're fat
like every problem you have is because
you're fat and now that I'm not like on
the brink of you know morbid obesity yes
I'm much more open to going I'll make an
appointment go to my gyno I feel like a
gyno is a regular doctor for women it's
not I've decided that to be no no that's
the case okay and she's amazing I have a
great guy now I also haven't been for a
pap smear in quite some time I'm just
I'm kind of just like rotting over here
I just I find pap smears to be the most
unpleasant of experience I love them
they're horrible I Cry
oh my God the metal
um
that is a medieval torture device they
Crank that [__] they just spread it wide
open and I always think like how is my
vagina really ever going to open to give
birth and now I I know how I get very
insecure that the gynecologist thinks I
like it because I am a lesbian but no it
would but I don't no well you're and I
do not consent I feel like a I feel like
a
gynecologist would assume that a
straight woman likes it more because
it's penetrative
you know in the life she was rubbing
unit speculum on your [__] maybe she
would think you enjoyed it you know what
if they did more women would go
regularly if they did go regularly
that's for him sure
I just hate and like I always she's like
we're gonna do STD tests and I'm like oh
yeah for sure but like I've only had one
partner and my husband is only in one
partner the way I am so jealous that you
guys are oh I love it it's my dream
thank you you know well I say I'm like
you can do it but like I don't need it
like we're just and she's like well you
never know and then she goes on these
horror stories about like yeah women who
got you know HPV and I'm like I'm sure
I'm like but that's not me okay but I'm
like yeah sure I guess you could do the
test should make it she knows a crazy
stories dinos know it all let me ask you
a question please do you manscape before
the guy now you have to it's the right
it's just common courtesy do you
manscape before like a spray tan
only the areas that are going to be seen
do you go vagina out with a spray tan
sometimes yeah girl I never I'm on like
a weird cycle with my spray tan artist
that I see her every time I have my
period how fun for her so when she
really says she doesn't mind and I wear
underwear and I'm wearing a tampon like
so she doesn't care but when I don't see
her on the days that I'm you know
menstruating yeah I go full I hate that
panty line line wait spring out string
out
you go with your string no I'm saying
when I don't have my period you don't
have your period I'll go full nude I'm
very comfortable with her that's so nice
I love a spray tan I get a different
woman every time which is not so fun for
me sometimes when I go to like a place
yeah you know like a sugared and bronze
when I when my girl's unavailable yeah
you never know who you're gonna get I go
I go like I'm going for a dick
appointment like I get you know shaved
everything like I have no leg hair no
armpit hair I have no mustache hair I go
so clean and fresh because I'm like I
don't want this what if this stranger is
a toaster does that ever do you ever
think about that I oh luckily I'm not
famous so it never happens so you are
you are you have like you have an
audience Taylor I haven't um I feel like
I'm I'm I'm Niche yeah maybe not well I
one time got a spray tan from like a
follower I think it was in Austin who
had reached out she's like I own a spray
tanning company okay so you knew going
in that she was a yes and I will say
like it was weird yeah she was such a
professional because you're so naked
yeah and it had nothing to do with her
she was amazing it was actually one of
the better spray tans I've ever gotten
in Austin yeah country yep but I was
like this is weird
I know this is weird I know I definitely
yeah I'm so naked and right now I'm like
so mushy and I'm just so dimply I'm so
saggy right now and they make me pull my
titties up I get that too it's shameful
no it's shameful like I get spray tans
um sometimes like with Margo like we'll
do it together and she's just have fun
everything stands up oh yeah tight so
they just go whoosh whoosh spray spray
spray for me they're like all right pick
your breasts up pick your other breasts
up lean forward so we can get under your
ass cheeks open your thighs like I have
all these oh I have these two I know
it's like Cirque du Soleil when I go in
there I'm doing yoga I'm doing Pilates
I'm putting my leg over my head just to
get under all my crevices and Margo's
just like swish swish swish turn around
swish swish swish same attack I know and
then I think that they were like judging
our relationship
you know because I think I often think
because I also weirdly follow a lot of
like estheticians yes on Tick Tock and
they get asked a lot of questions like
especially women who do like Brazilian
waxes and stuff being like does it gross
you out when this and this and they're
really lovely women and they're like
it's just the human body they always say
the only thing that really grosses us
out is when you have like particles of
like feces in your nether regions you
know and she's like that's gross but for
the most particles of feces she really
worded it very nicely because I'm like
what is this [__] trying to say I'm
like Duty
dingleberries dingleberry yes she didn't
want to use you know she was using the
medical term particles of feces
but for the most part they say they
don't get weird wait wait is that common
yes yes yes
oh you know like when the toilet paper
gets stuck in the vagina oh they see
that too sometimes but they say like a
lot like we don't judge and a lot of
things like don't bother us but I'm a
human being and I know if this was my
job like every little thing other people
do with disgust me disgust me ingrown
hair ew let me excavate it for you no
get off my table get out I fired you
with the client yeah that's why I would
I could just I could never be I don't
think an esthetician I could be a
dermatologist a facialist like I could
pop no I see random strangers on the
street no I want to offer like hey let
me get that big black hat on your nose
girl I know but I've never done that to
you you actually have lovely skin too
thank you I mean you can pull my pimples
whenever you want I would love to and by
the way don't get offended like if I
ever see one on your face I will go
after it I think I'm hiding one by
myself
no I really don't I'm very lucky boss
was called meant to be on my skin when
we were in middle school together yeah I
don't know if you've ever heard Taylor
tell the story which she's told 1065
times she went to the same high school
as Kate Bosworth and they have a current
mutual friend we do who you met at my
birthday party oh was that who it was
Chris oh I should have cozied up to him
a little bit hello so him and Kate are
still tight oh hell yeah he's going to
that wedding he had dinner with her and
Justin long and said very much in love I
believe it he never talked [__] about
Kate which kills me yeah that's tough
for whatever he's a good friend have you
been following the Sofia Richie wedding
in the south of France I have I have I
you know I'm I'm kind of a newbie Tick
Tock yeah I saw you join Tick Tock
congratulations thank you thank you very
much thank you I'm gonna like it's more
like podcast clips and things of that
nature but a girl's gonna try every now
and then to like keep up with the trend
pop off you know I love that do a little
voice over do a little dance make a
Little Love Get Down Tonight
get down tonight how's it going you're
Tick Tock Journey I'm terrible that was
me it still is me but that was me you
should talk to Hannah burner she gave me
some really good advice I know I know
I'm gonna have to have a little pow-wow
with her I'm just gonna have to have her
on the podcast so you can like put her
Clips up and they'll go viral oh duh
that is yeah you too yeah I would love
to stassi's well honestly I'm the best
social climber I've ever met in my life
I actually I bet some the thing is
you're a social climber but like in a
really kind of earnest and not annoying
and genuine way thank you and like
actual social climbers like people who
actually just use people yes disgusting
and then get to another level and kick
the person beneath them those people are
like actually disgusting no so like for
you to call yourself that is actually
inaccurate because you're like a
wonderful person thank you I'm Glenn to
the good witch you're Glenda the Good
Witch I am so alphaba
yeah yeah you are I have been changed
I literally did this with Ben when he
was co-hosting like two days ago he
didn't know it either four good do we
have to go see Wicked I mean no
are you not a wicked girly I just
remember we just talked about how we
don't love going to the theater Wicked
is not the theater oh excuse her I saw I
mean I saw it years ago wait are you not
like a like but wait you love musical
theater we're always doing karaoke you
always go to Marie's crisis and sing
show tunes I only know Defying Gravity
but like the um what should we call it
leadership version well the clean
version of every song is better so I
respect that thank you I mean don't talk
to me about Only the Good Die Young by
Billy Joel because that's a Glee version
that popped all the way [__] off so
good and half the music I know that's
like from you know the early 2000s or
earlier no the 90s or earlier yeah I
only know because of Glee Oh my God that
Bottom Girls you make the rocking
squirrel go round only because of Glee
well that's not like a queen like top 10
hit you know I mean it was sung to me a
lot growing up well you're a hundred
so that actually tracked and I've got a
big ass General so oh that's why I was
sung to you exactly no I loved that song
even though like the guy who sang it on
the Glee version it was you know a child
trafficking pedophile can you even how
dare he how dare him how dare he ruin
everything I can't even watch the show
anymore oh I can I can oh God whenever I
see his character I'm like there's so
many things on Glee Oh wait sorry I was
talking about the Sofia Richie wedding
because oh yeah I didn't make it a story
today but me and Ben were just like
speculating yesterday about you know
Benji and Joe Madden were there because
that's Nicole Richie's brother wait I
mean husbands right but Benji Angel yeah
they invited Joel and uh Cameron Cameron
yeah no kidding and so Ben is you know
obsessed with emo music just like your
wife and we were dying to know whether
Good Charlotte performed at the wedding
and now we've gotten a lot of footage
and they performed at the after party
lifestyle of the rich and the famous and
everyone was like [__] like rocking
out because that's their Anthem it
looked so fun Ben was like actually
having fomo from a while he never would
have been invited to him was Julianne
Hough there or did I make that up you
made that up I think God why would you
you've been there I don't know but there
was somebody speaking in it like it was
from behind blonde kind of had
Julianne's voice I know I just feel like
everyone in Hollywood looks like
Julianne Huff I agree and Lionel Richie
we were speculating whether he did sing
of course he did he has to um I think
he's saying while her and her husband
had their first dance which is so sweet
very sweet I mean that so it's all about
the it's like
um succession billionaire status Vibes
only what's the term stuff baby oh you
got that too stealth wealth I like that
stealth wealth is like okay so you know
what succession how like they don't okay
remember that scene with top succession
yes I love it but don't tell me about it
well no I just want to say I just now
figured out but that Conor the older
brother is the actor from Ferris Bueller
did you know that of course I'm a
thousand he's the one whose dad has the
red car right yes I had no idea at my
book club last night everyone was
talking about like TV shows they've been
watching everyone was like can you
believe that's the guy I'm like excuse
me oh my God were you shook I had no
idea and that's like I only recently
found out that Tom womsgam okay is Mr
Marcy from Pride and Prejudice huh the
Kira Knightley one Tom shiv's ex-husband
yes it yes yes I know who Tom is oh wait
he plays Mr Darcy in the Keira Knightley
Pride and Prejudice never heard of her
wait you never heard of Keira Knightley
never heard of any of it oh at her Pride
and Prejudice in the movie yeah but like
never saw it Mr die you know what it's
too Booky
by the way I actually hate that film and
like my family loved it growing up and
every time they would put it on I'd be
like enough with this [__] movie I'm
gonna blow this house up but putting
together that it was Tom wamscam was was
shocking for me I'm sorry continue also
the dad
is do you know match point it's a Woody
Allen song like of course I know match
it's my favorite movie I watched every
night he is the data match point I
haven't seen that movie in forever so I
only know Scarlett Johansson and
Jonathan Rhys Meyer yes he is
um everybody else's dad not their dad
he's like the father-in-law essential
okay wait I have to watch match point
that movie's such a like a [__] Niche
reference I watch it every single night
fall asleep really it's not psychotic
wait is that oh no it's not Kate Bob's
worth it's it's Scarlett Johansson I
could not watch Kate Potter to go to
sleep no you would have nice nightmares
okay so I'm sorry continue about Stealth
wealth stealth wealth so they're like
now because of succession everyone's
breaking down this idea of like stealth
wealth so remember the episode where Tom
is coming for the girl with like an
enormous purse her lewdest circapacious
purse what does she have in there flats
for the subway i'm like [__] yes okay
so it's all about how billionaires like
in subtle ways they show you how rich
they are but like very quietly right
like having a big purse which is
seemingly innocuous right so a very tiny
person says I'm rich because like I
don't need all my [__] except my car
downstairs or like I just I I get driven
everywhere I don't need shoes for the
Subway or I don't need like a credit
card it's all on file exactly yeah but
the number one thing is I don't need a
jacket
why would you need a jacket to ruin your
outfit it's so true you just get in the
car and get out and so me and my poor
ass jacket running around the city so
true I actually never wear jackets and
it's not because I'm a billionaire sadly
it's because like I just can't but
you're wearing one right now well this
isn't like an outdoor jacket this is
that's true stylish I could see Kendall
wearing like a jacket like that I meant
like weather jackets got you like that
you take off that's not a part of your
outfit
it could be snowing and I won't wear a
jacket I can't be bothered stealth
wealth no I wish just um stealth
stubbornness like I just can't
I'm like running I'm just I just can't
it's like such a burden so
now they're saying that the Richie
wedding was very stealthy wealthy it was
very you know what for as much as it is
like this unattainable level of Fame and
money yeah something about it maybe it
was just like the way she was sharing so
much on social media something about it
felt like extremely relatable in a sense
I agree it's just like a regular girl
she's not and I mean yeah he's a
billionaire but he's like a a regular
guy in a sense he's not a mom or a
certain lady I know I saw that because
she brought um her mom for the Vogue
thing you know her all her dresses were
made by Chanel and Vogue did the whole
thing for the final fitting they did
this video that was really cute
um so she brought I think like her maid
of honor or her friend or whatever and
her mother-in-law and they were like
this is my mother-in-law lady whatever
I'm like lady does that mean does that
title get passed on to Sophia and Elliot
God I hope so for her sake that's
fabulous she's so stunning and I know
that like that's how genetics work but
she really looks like her dad it's crazy
like when they had the pictures of them
walking down the aisle they have the
same exact face she's spectacular you
know I mean really what an example of we
can do whatever we want in life yeah she
was dating Scott Disick I mean it's in
an example of you can do whatever you
want in life when you have unlimited
like Fame and weight and that's just a
small detail I don't think we should
just glaze over you know the nepo of it
all another element I'm sorry we're
talking about this but I didn't make it
a story but it's like so in the no it's
like it's truly everywhere right now and
something I'm loving seeing I literally
oftentimes forget that her Nicole Richie
are siblings and the way they have such
a special bond like I didn't even really
I never even think about them as
siblings but Nicole Richie was posting
so much she's like I love my sister so
much it was video like pictures from the
photographer and Nicole Richie's just
like had so many tears and her eyes and
she's looking at her sister so lovingly
it was really so sweet I literally
forgot that they were siblings how many
years apart like at least like 10 right
more I love it that's how I feel about
my little brother right I feel like
Nicole Richie's I feel like Sophie is
like 24 25 yeah and Nicole has to be in
her 40s by now because Paris is when you
have a sibling that's like 10 years or
more like younger than you you feel like
they're your actual baby yeah I actually
called both my siblings Paige and Zach
the kids how many age years Paige is
like seven and Zach's like 11. oh wow I
know right yeah I guess there's also
probably a period where you don't have
much in common no because you're like
I'm off in college and he's like in
middle school 12. and then when they
like grow up a little bit and you're
grown like you probably have like a
Renaissance like you just love them you
know like let's smoke cigarettes right
right which is horrible to do as an
older sister no someone's got to do it
don't tell my mom I said that well does
your mom listen to the toast she will
today if somebody tells her to I love
your mom she's Fab she's Fab like I know
what you're gonna sound like when you're
50 or her world I already sound like her
because you have like this like kind of
sexy Smoker's wrasse thank you I love
your sexy you know babsy has not smoked
a cigarette a day in her life she sounds
like she does I know so that's like so
it's not my fault I sound like this
you're predisposed yes yes be determined
predetermined I was just helping it
along in my early 20s are you ready to
dive into the past five stories I'm very
excited I haven't looked at the news
today so this is all a journey so the
first story okay here are the fast five
stories that you need to to know today's
episode is brought to you by Babel if
you have an upcoming summer trip abroad
our go-to travel hack is Babel whether
you're a seasoned traveler or embarking
on your first Adventure communication is
key communicado is key and if you want
to fully experience a new culture check
out Babel Babel is the language learning
app that sold more than 10 million
subscriptions and thanks to their
addictively fun and easy bite-sized
language lessons there's still time to
learn a new language before you reach
your destination don't be like me don't
be saying Bon Nui to everyone thinking
that it means something when it actually
doesn't with Babel you only need 10
minutes to complete a lesson so you can
start having real-life conversations in
as little as three weeks Babel's
expertly crafted lessons are built
around real life you will learn how to
have practical conversations about
travel relationships businesses and more
so other language learning apps are
using AI for their lesson plans but
Babel lessons were created by over 150
language experts and they are voiced by
real native speakers not computers with
Babel there's 14 different languages to
choose from and their speech recognition
technology helps you improve your
pronunciation and accent so no one's
going to make fun of you abroad you can
ask you know for directions or where the
bathroom is without looking like a
fraudulent Queen there are so many ways
to learn with Babel in addition to their
lessons you can get access to podcasts
Games videos stories and even live
classes right now get 55 off your
subscription when you go to babel.com
toast that's babble.com toast for up to
55 off your subscription Babble language
for life you know that's Jackie's
favorite Babble you guys check it out
today's episode is also brought to you
by Perfect bar looking for nutritious
and delicious snack will look no further
than perfect bar with their lineup of
fresh from the fridge protein bars
perfect bar is exactly what you and your
family need spring cleaning your fridge
should be fun so why not toss out those
Dusty condiments and replace them with a
perfect bar they're made from freshly
ground nut butter organic honey and 20
organic superfoods perfect bar has a
variety of products like protein bars
little snack size bars that are also
good and good for you you'll be sure to
find something you love Ben Soffer just
discovered the perfect bar and now I
have none left in my house because
that's what happens when I enjoy
something and then Ben figures it out
our favorite is the chocolate chip
cookie dough it's so delicious it's a
great go-to snack throw it in your purse
at the beginning of the day it'll keep
you full and energized all day long the
texture is a cookie dough texture it's
really creamy it's full of flavor it's
packed with up to six grams of proteins
the snack size one so it's really
perfect to throw into your purse the
bigger bars have up to 17 grams of
protein and comes in over 10 flavors
they're made with whole food ingredients
they contain no artificial preservatives
perfect bar is stored in the fridge so
grab one after a workout or for a quick
bite while you're out perfect bar knows
that it'll be Love At First Bite so for
a limited time they're offering you a
chance to try the refrigerated protein
bars for free here's how it works sign
up for email or text and upload a
picture of your receipt from your local
grocery store and they'll reimburse you
for the cost of one bar it'll go
directly into your venmo or PayPal
account all you have to do is go to
perfect snacks.com toast to get a free
perfect bar today that's perfect
snacks.com
t-o-a-s-t to get that free perfect bar
today happy snacking and yet welcome
from the toast we're helping you get
free delicious snacks what's better than
that the first story is like taking the
World by storm and there's a lot of
conflicting opinions on this whole Glen
Powell Sydney Sweeney thing oh oh okay
let's go so Glenn Powell and Sydney
Sweeney are cozing up right after his
girlfriend has unfollowed Sydney Sweeney
okay so Glenn Powell and Sydney Sweeney
looked extremely cozy at cinemacon in
Las Vegas on Monday despite his long
time time love on following Sophie so
Sydney Sweeney on social media so Glenn
Powell and Sydney Sweeney who attended
the convention to promote their upcoming
movie anyone but you couldn't keep their
eyes off each other as they posed for
photos on the red carpet in one eyebrow
raising photo in particular Sydney
Sweeney can be seen looking up at Glenn
Powell and beaming as he looks at the
cameras yep and all this comes after
like it's been like a couple of weeks of
like really weird photos coming out of
Sydney Sweeney and Glenn Powell like a
broad filming promoting and just like
looking like a couple but everyone's
like oh that's cute they're really close
co-stars because he obviously has his
girlfriend Gigi Paris right but Gigi
Paris yesterday or like two days ago
unfollowed Glenn who'd she'd been dating
since 2020 and then a spark speculation
that they broke up and then um she
unfollowed Sydney Sweeney
so I mean there's definitely something
going on you don't unfollow your
boyfriend unfollow is big unfollow's
huge I know and so a lot of people are
like shipping Glenn Powell and Sydney
Sweeney yeah so hard that they don't
even care that like maybe they cheated
on this GG girl I feel like this is
happening more and more and more we are
like a moralist society you're so we are
a moralist society yeah like nobody
cares about the ethics because they're
just so like obsessed and by the way I
get it like Sydney Sweeney and Glenn
Powell I'm obsessed with this couple let
me tell you why I think this is exactly
what Glenn Powell needs like Glenn
Powell is like a movie star yes in the
sense that he was in Top Gun and he you
know was a huge actor and he gets but
he's not like so famous but he's very
recognizable but yes he's not there's
like an element to his Fame and career
that's missing something and I think
it's like a star-studded love affair yes
and Sydney Sweeney is the it girl of the
moment right now girl I'm obsessed with
her last I heard she was in like a
long-term committed almost I think
engaged relationship to like some older
nobody yeah and it was kind of like a
letdown because it's like girl you're
City Sweeney like go [__] Jacob lordy or
something like do something fabulous
right so for both of these people in
terms of a career I love it but there is
an underlying ethical issue and how do
we deal with it Taylor
you know it's just sad it's Case by case
it's scary
like we know cheating is bad like right
now scandival we are Furious I know but
you know there's an element I've been
thinking a lot about Scandal recently I
don't think you're gonna like what I
have to say I don't think I'm going to
either there's an element of Scandal
that I mean I'm so team Ariana it's
disgusting like I'm not I just need to
get that out yes but and me and Jackie
were talking about this because like in
the coming weeks after scandaval there
was an element of like ickiness to how
so many of the cast members were like
piling on to like an insane level with
their merch and their podcasts and yes
it just felt weird given you know there
are a lot of people who believe that you
know Ariana was the one who broke up
Kristen and Tom and Kristen was the one
who broke up Stasi and Jax and Lala was
the one who broke up a full-blown
marriage Sheena started this entire show
by being the mistress in Eddie Cibrian
and Brandi glanville's marriage so it's
a lot of like [__] in Glass Houses
throwing hella stones and that doesn't
make what Raquel and Tom did better it
doesn't make it no good but I think
everyone needs to take a hard long look
in the mirror I do find shreds of
hypocrisy for sure well and I also have
talked about the fact that like why is
this story like this big because like
you just said we have the christening
Jacks we have the Sandoval and Ariana we
have the Lala I mean you know she's
since explained that and I do believe
because this recent episode of VPR I
actually didn't watch the most recent
episode but she's on this like Warpath
of refusing to be called a mistress so
she explains it made sense to me so okay
there's this uh spoiler whatever it's
your fault you deserved I'm late so
Raquel um has this whole thing with
Oliver garcelle's and it comes out that
he's actually still married and he told
her he was not anyway so they have
dinner they talk it through and he's
kind of like listen we are separated but
yes sometimes we take a step backwards
she's like we have children together so
anyway he kind of admitted like yeah
they sleep together every now and then
but it doesn't mean they're back
together and he still has his own place
whatever so she kind of gets in the fold
and so Lala says to her like you know
what don't let anybody call you a
mistress which is like hilarious because
she literally three seconds before just
called her mistress but I think what
Lala understood was like wait so I did
think that you were a mistress in the
case of or mistress Vibes in the case of
Katie and Schwartz because you were
asked not to go there yeah but in the
case of Oliver who technically is
married not your fault he didn't tell
you and she kind of said like I got
duped too men are very good at Pokemon
over like the other woman's eyes Okay
well that might be like a fair
explanation but it's also important to
note that Lala slept with James while he
was with Raquel so right right so right
I'm just saying the the underlying
layers of hypocrisy run strong guess
absolutely
you know that's
that thing and I think that was actually
what Tom Sandoval was trying to say when
he did that
oh [__] it was horrible for everybody
involved it was it was an embarrassment
I don't know who I was most embarrassed
for I I think Howie I think Howie's
daughter
you know she was the only one that knew
what the hell was going on right and she
let the whole charade go on without
pressing any how he has no idea who any
of these people are I can't even blame
him for like letting Tom Sandoval spew
his lies because he doesn't know what we
know she should have been like Dad shut
up and let me take the lead I know so I
actually blame her the most if I'm gonna
be honest but that's not the point I
weirdly blame Howie the most yeah he
said so many offensive things too he
really did like the whole time I did
love though that he went on this um
tangent about how is Tom Schwartz not
Jewish because I have often thought
about that too I know but like it was
just wasn't it a lot although it didn't
bother me the Jewish stuff because
honestly the first few years of watching
the show I just assumed Tom shorts was
Jewish hilarious and nobody talks about
that like how do you have the last name
Schwartz
it's good that's like your name being
Barbara Goldstein and you're telling me
you're not Jewish I wish it were I know
is that weird yeah you're that's a very
good point you're right by the way total
tangent but like I guess we make any
excuse on this podcast to talk about
your ex marriage yes please did it ever
occur to you to keep your married last
name were you ever Taylor whatever that
last one you can't say out of respect
okay because I'm so respectful yeah and
also I know you love being Jewish and it
was a Jewish last name it was a very
Jewish last name you lived so much so
the key when we were like traveling like
we wanted to go to Dubai yeah and it was
like honestly with our last names we can
this was a different time yeah but like
you concur that that's a thing a lot of
people are very trepidatious it's like
Sex in the City she goes by Charlotte
York golden black she's like it's the
Middle East it's the new Middle East
it's the Middle East exactly so yeah but
it was definitely identifiably Jewish
yes
um I actually never got around to
changing my name because your girl hates
paperwork the Same by the way I've never
changed my name but I but like for a
while I did have this weird hybrid when
we got married I changed my name like at
Town Hall to Taylor Ashley's my middle
name and then his last name right but
like why wouldn't I do Taylor strecker
his last name anyway yeah thank God I
never finished it because then post
divorce no I was just curious and also
his last name
um from a pop culture standpoint was not
really bad yeah that's such a good point
so thank God I didn't change it because
I would have definitely had to change it
back such a good point right
um okay so back to Glenn Powell and
Sydney Sweeney like while I do ship I
think it's important to acknowledge how
infidelity is wrong no yeah it's wrong
but I'm still here for them I know I
mean we make exceptions for people that
we like I know I kind of like I'm
obsessed with this couple like they're
so good looking they're both Rising
Stars I love it they're both going to be
like huge like you know they're gonna be
I'm I'm just obsessed like I I feel bad
I know for her because and that's the
thing too like you it's like you get
besmirched Yeah by somebody doing that
to you I know and then no one cares
because they're so happy for Sydney
Sweeney England palette it's actually
really sad that's like my biggest fear
is like Tay and I don't make it she like
leaves me for somebody else you I'm so
down
and people are like [__] Taylor tracker
this is amazing yeah no like if me and
Taylor Donna whoever did get together
like no one would really feel bad for
you because it would be like new power
couple literally but you can get
together with Ben though you guys really
fine I'll take back you guys really do
get along so well I love Ben I just feel
like at some point we all need to like
live in a commune together it would be
so much better you know we've talked
about this with my sister and
brother-in-law who you're obsessed with
oh they can come too I'm obsessed with
Taylor these baby sister dead ass about
it like Ben literally said to me we're
um out for Halloween in Brooklyn Heights
yeah and he's not my Ben her
brother-in-law my brother-in-law and he
was like these houses are sick and he's
like hey if we take my money and your
money we get somebody [__] sick no
and then if I join we can get another
house we could really get something like
three people is better than two we get
like a castle in Kentucky where Jackson
Britney got married it's just like
that's not the that's not the not fun
part of being an adult it's like you
can't just like live with your friends
but like who says I know let's do it I'm
so down you end up living like we all
just like live on the same block you
know okay so let's talk let's talk will
can I get you to move to New Hope Tay is
dead
well then the talk is over there's no
like I'm really Limited in where I can
move because there has to be like a
thriving Jewish community that is
absolutely fair so I know your in-laws
live in New Jersey I would go to New
Jersey in a second okay there's many
good Jewish schools and Jewish
communities and temples they have kosher
restaurants The Hamptons is very Jewish
West Hampton specifically maybe we can
start with like um a vacation property
together uh by the way I love that idea
we'll have to figure out how like the
tax situation works but you do realize
that usually like real estate with
friends and family is the thing that
tears everybody apart oh is it why
because of money it's like the number
one thing really yeah it's like an old
wives tale like do not like to real
estate with friends ever if you love
people family friends don't it will ruin
your relationship that is so interesting
but I feel like we're better than that I
feel like we're beyond that next thing
you know we're not talking to each other
in five years
ready for our next story yes please some
drama do you see this Morgan Wallen
thing no so we basically um he's on an
arena tour he's playing uh sorry excuse
me stadiums like 60 000 people okay and
he was in Mississippi and he has three
opening acts everyone is seated the
three opening acts go three opening acts
is a lot I know but for a stadium tour
it's actually not okay
um it's his turn to go
literally the screens light up sorry
Show's canceled
people have been there for hours
watching the uh opening acts getting
merch buying drinks
they're sitting in the seats and the
Show is canceled which is really unheard
of how dare you like we were going off
on Adele for canceling her residency
like a couple of days before maybe a
week and I mean this is next level what
happened so there were a lot of
speculation about what actually happened
his line and his statements were like he
lost his voice he was working all day
with doctors doing all these things
getting his voice back and he was up
until the very last minute trying to you
know get his voice back and and he
couldn't okay true is understandable
right you really if your voice is wonky
you got to cancel the morning of but
whatever there were a lot of rumors very
unfounded like you know people at the
stadium who were working security
basically saying he was wasted people
said they saw him at a bar before none
of that is founded on anything but it's
really easy to believe given his you
know problematic background he's our
problematic country King right and now
he's being sued for canceling that
Mississippi concert minutes before
Showtime by the venue no by fans so
that's a thing I I don't know so a
Morgan wallenson I'm in a crazy world I
know it's like if this actually
that's what it is shut the [__] up so if
it actually like happens it sets a
precedent for absolutely yeah and I was
just thinking because we were talking
last week when you were on the toast
about Frank Ocean canceling yeah
um that was like five or six days maybe
a week but people did buy tickets for
him so wait riddle me this so had he
canceled the day of like the morning of
right because I remember Britney Spears
did that to me and I was devastated I'm
so sorry it was k-fed's fault it was but
like I certainly didn't file a class
action lawsuit because I'm not a loser
right um but I do feel like that's like
so crazy to me
raged for for us for the industry but
the thing is is like had he canceled the
morning of Allah Brittany for me it's
like so you don't have to physically get
yourself there go and can you get your
tickets back but that's a thing just
because an artist cancels no matter how
much time they give you like um Jan
Jackson canceled because she was
pregnant at the age of 85 right and then
she but she was like oh yeah well I'll
rebook it and so like we couldn't get
refunded so I hate the people do that
that happened to me and Kelly Clarkson's
Las Vegas residency and then because of
kovich ended up canceling the whole
thing so we actually got our money back
I think a full year later
um but it depends what the artist wants
to do they they sometimes reschedule um
like immediately like the next date is
June your tickets will be valid then and
you can't get a refund for this thing he
said all um tickets will be refunded at
point of purchase then what so let me
tell you so um fan is suing the country
singer on Monday for canceling a concert
minutes before Showtime Brandi birchman
filed a class action lawsuit on behalf
of herself and other similar similarly
situated patrons who attended wallen's
show in Oxford Mississippi on Sunday
only to be told that the 11th Hour that
he had lost his voice Burcham the woman
suing said in court documents obtained
by Page Six that while the venue
promised refunds at point of purchase
hers had yet to be issued when she filed
the complaint okay I mean it's been two
days I mean it takes what five to seven
I mean my metro card didn't work and I
just bought it the other day and like I
have to mail it in like that Dems are
the breaks no that's like how Banks work
you can't get a refund before like five
or seven days but whatever okay she said
even if ticket prices are refunded no
offer has been made to reimburse concert
goers for other out-of-pocket expenses
they incurred well in connection with
the concert cancellation including
Transportation lodging food merchandise
sales transaction fees and other such
expenses as well merch is a choice well
it's not a necessity so here's the thing
she's suing for breach of contract and
negligence in addition to demanding a
trial by jury I hate her so the thing is
is I don't know what do we chalk this up
to do we chalk this up to you know like
life sucks and life is unfair and yeah
you gotta sit her for a show that ended
up being canceled or
are we then know you know I was
displaced there should be someone to
blame I don't know like what are is this
a legal issue or is this just you know A
Hard Knock Life
this girl is like a total spoiled brat
she's distressed like energy like her
privilege is like shooting out of her
butthole like oh my God like that's life
[__] happens it is but like part of me
also sympathizes with like a couple a
couple who got a sitter maybe went away
for the weekend got a hotel spent money
on merch and drinks for a concert and
then didn't end up needing the merch or
the drinks because the concert never
happened well it's like yeah that sucks
and so do I just Chuck that up to like
you know what life is unfair and
sometimes things happen or it's like no
you know what I was put out I want my
money back here's the thing so like you
know the girl
um with Adele I think I brought this up
last time and she um was in Vegas and it
was like her fifth time trying to see
Adele and every flown there and then
literally the minute she landed it got
canceled yes and she was like she did a
whole Tick Tock it was hilarious but she
was like not again like this poor girl
could not catch a break when it came to
Adele right and the amount of money she
spent traveling in the world hotels the
whole shebang so like my heart went out
to her specifically if she had done this
I might have been like okay fine yeah
she's every right but like and I got at
this like yes if you have to pay for
flights and for like hotels that's
insane babysitters like if Beyonce does
this when people are like traveling all
over the world for her right and this is
the type of concert like people can't
get tickets to it's insanely expensive
so like people are traveling far and
wide to go so like yes I understand that
portion but like girl you lost me on the
merch and the drinks the thing is like
just because you bought merch and the
concert didn't happen doesn't mean you
can't still wear the merch I understand
like being annoyed paying for drinks
it's like I got drunk for a show and now
I just have to drive home there'll be a
blanket I get drunk everywhere so like
same same like I'm gonna be getting
drunk no matter where I am yeah I don't
know and I'm not a lawyer I don't know
if from a legal standpoint this has like
any like she has to lose she will lose
because
crazy precedent well then nobody's going
to want to perform anymore because like
then they're liable for all these people
that's insane because [__] really does
happen like you know
Sean Mendes recently canceled a big tour
like uh Justin Bieber canceled his whole
tour because of his Ramsay Hunt Syndrome
like people are human they get sick they
get you know mental health crises like
these things happen and I think you're
more susceptible to these things when
you're traveling non-stop working
performing streaming for other people of
course susceptible to losing your voice
so I do think if this were to actually
like he would like actually get sued I
do think it sets a really bad precedence
horrible and here's the thing too if I
was not to say what he did was like it
was unequivocally wrong I'm sorry you
owe people more than five minutes notice
I agree but then also like if he was
refusing to refund ticket sales then yes
like denim yeah but this I mean he's
doing good by you okay but how does it
work when you are refunding everyone for
the show but like let's say I bought my
tickets on StubHub like from some guy
right do I get a refund
good question I know because most people
like actually don't buy their tickets on
Ticketmaster I feel like when a stadium
tour goes live half the tickets get sold
to scalpers and Bots and they resell
them and people buy resale tickets right
but see this is the issue it's like the
way I feel about health care insurance
companies are the devil not the doctors
versus the patients it's true now we're
like artists versus the fans yeah it's
the ticket people I mean you're 100
right because everyone should just be
able to buy tickets directly from the
artist exactly and so when they do a
refund it's not a big deal exactly
totally I hate this woman by the way you
hate Brenda I hate Brenda you're not
Randy her name's Randy
Brenda energy Brandy you're not into
you're not giving Brandy Burcham energy
today no I'm not I'm good yeah it's
gonna be like distressed energy yeah
exactly today's episode is brought to
you by Skylight frames with Mother's Day
and Father's Day coming up are you ready
to be the favorite Child and get the
best gift ever so with the new Skylight
digital photo frame it'll bring joy on a
daily basis watching photos cycle and
seeing new ones come in is so exciting
and if you have a relative who's not how
do we put this who's that the most
technologically sound it is so easy to
set up it is so easy to send photos to
and it really keeps the whole family
together when people either live far
away or you haven't seen family in a
while it's really great so if you're
struggling to stay connected to a loved
ones give a skylight frame you can send
new photos to it every day and there's a
really special way to stay connected
it's also really beautiful it's hard to
find frames that aren't like ugly
um and the Skylight One is great because
it's digital so you can add and change
the photos but it's really beautiful so
it'll look great on your mantel it's
really the perfect gift for Mother's Day
coming up and Father's Day coming up so
it's a great way to feel close to those
that you love even when you're far away
and it's really a gift that the whole
family could enjoy because anyone can
send photos to the frame anytime from
anywhere it's truly the gift that keeps
on giving so the frame is gorgeous you
can choose from either a 10 inch or a 15
inch touchscreen it's super fun to swipe
through all the photos you can tap it to
give like a little heart a little like
it holds thousands of photos that
continuously rotate and bring joy they
have 100 satisfaction guarantee if you
don't love your Skylight they will offer
you a full refund so when you get it for
Mother's Day you can pre-load it set it
up for your mom or your dad ad preload
it with thousands of photos and surprise
them with photos that they didn't even
know you had so now is a special offer
in time for Mother's Day and Father's
Day get 10 off that's up to 30 off your
frame when you go to skylightframe.com
toast that's right 10 off up to 30 off
your purchase of a skylight frame when
you go to skylightframe.com toast that's
s-k-y-l-i-g-h-t-f-r-a-m-e.com slash
toast today's episode is also brought to
you by a new sponsor that we're really
excited about I know Jackie is it's
carry Uma so I have a really hard time
finding shoes that are comfortable that
I can walk around in all day that really
support my whole body because you guys
know I've been like struggling with my
back and that's where carry Uma comes in
the sponsor of today's episode they are
reimagining classic sneakers with you
and the planet in mind and now that
spring has officially sprung we're
trading out our boots and our cold
weather kicks for something a little
lighter and brighter so carry Uma shoes
are crafted with organic cotton canvas
and they spring shape and they come in
Spring Shades like rose off-white and
green and of course their best seller
the OCA low is sure to become your
staple shoe of the season they just
cleared a 77 000 person wait list so
with over 10 colorways bold prints and
collaborations with Brands like Avatar
Pantone and the peanuts there's a pair
for every personality they have over 33
000 five-star reviews carry Uma is a b
Corp certified sustainable sneaker
company so they're known for their
restoration efforts in the Brazilian
Rainforest their co-founders both grew
up in Brazil so for every pair of
sneakers sold hariuma is planting two
trees and they've over planted over 2
million to date so not only you can walk
around with stylish comfortable guards
issues you're also helping the planet so
I really can't see a reason why I need
to explain any further to you why you
should head over to caroluma.com you
know carry Uma shoots all their sneakers
free and fast in the US and for a
limited time the toast listeners can get
an exclusive 15 off your pair of
carayuma sneakers when you go to
kariyuma.com toast for that 15 off so
that's
c-a-r-i-u-m-a.com slash toast for 15 off
it's only for a limited time so head
over to kariyuma
c-a-r-i-u-m-a.com slash toast all right
next up Alec ball Baldwin he's feeling
grateful for all the support he's gotten
as he is resuming filming for the movie
rust which is the movie where Helena
Hutchins gets shot and killed I'm kind
of surprised they didn't just say the
movie's done I mean it's not like it's a
big Blockbuster it's like an independent
crap movie like yeah it's why are they
finishing this movie I just I I think
you know him with the charges I think it
was a lot I'm relieved for him and his
family you know I'm sad for the victims
families and because I know that they
need closure but I don't know that him
going to prison for that was necessarily
my pleasure I agree like I'm like hating
Alec Baldwin because I think the way
he's handled this has been like so
disrespectful and him and his wife like
talking to Paparazzi and just like being
really I just feel like they could be
way more gracious for the woman who very
tragically lost her life and while it
wasn't Alex fault he literally you know
held the gun so I don't think he Bears
any legal responsibility I don't think
he deserves to go to jail but I'm really
just like I'm like offended by how kind
of gross he's been acting especially his
wife they have big victim energy yeah
major yeah yeah so I don't know why this
film has to resume and he posted on his
Instagram he just filmed finished
filming a movie called supercell he said
I just filmed supercell in Billings and
now I'm outside of Bozeman to complete
rust Montana is stunning I'm grateful
for all the support I have received here
and this comes on the heels of the Santa
Fe County District Attorney's office
dropping the charges against him without
prejudice
so he was initially facing up to five
years in prison but he got a major legal
Victory when the DA's office announced
that they were dropping the gun
enhancement charges against him in
February
I still feel like there's something
there's such a weird element to this
story and I I don't think charging Alec
was a way to get down to the bottom of
how a live bullet got on set I agree but
I hope this isn't the end I know I just
feel like it's in such poor taste to
continue the movie I know if they could
do you would want to see this movie not
I after some a mother a young mother
yeah who the [__] cares to be honest I
didn't want to see the movie ever before
the tragedy you're so right it's a
western
if it's a western amount if it's an
independent Western I'm definitely out
and honestly Alec Baldwin he's had some
great some great films I know I don't
think he's like a great actor of our
time I just watched It's Complicated the
best movie ever he's actually I'm sorry
he's amazing in that he's so to Die For
in that I know he actually looks like
handsome I know do you watch 30 Rock I
actually just recently started and it's
everything it's the best show on
television it's so good and he's amazing
amazing he's amazing in it I know but
beyond that sorry he's not a great actor
I'm very conflicted when it comes to him
I am too because I'm so in love with 30
Rock and I loved his character and I
love it's complicated so I definitely
feel like you know a kinship yeah
spirited you know connection but in
recent years he's especially with his
wife he's just become so goddamn
annoying his Achilles heel a hundred
percent I think he's always been
teetering remember the the fat little
pig comment no what was it a thoughtless
little pig thoughtless little pig but um
I'm beating up the paparazzi I think
he's using oh yeah like he you know
crazy problematic history but he's just
one of those people where like people
don't seem to care right but then it's
like other people do one thing a million
years ago and like you can't let it go
it's so interesting how we like treat
every yeah quote-unquote cancellation
and Scandal so differently just double
standards based on how we feel about the
person literally and I feel like when a
woman does something like we never let
it go it's 10 000 times worse it's what
they're known for known a writer will
forever be a klepto well yeah she did
steal that [__] so
you're right like we like treat certain
people and their scandals so differently
I know it's crazy like I mean Chris
Brown is my favorite example Jesus I
mean he's out here selling out Arenas
and it's all women going I'll never
understand some [__] like I know some
[__] be dumb
like I have friends like people I know
who like love Chris Brown I'm like
you're disgusting really yeah someone we
know I'll tell you after no way
I'll tell you everything okay I'm so
excited to judge them um Alec Baldwin
wishing you the best I feel like
definitely a break would be good
yeah I'm always for people taking breaks
like you know in the public space the
break never hurt anybody no and I think
Hillary
I won't dignify her fraudulent
Background by calling her ilaria Hillary
and Alec need you know they have a lot
of money they need to just go to the
Hamptons or something and chill
play with their kids they've got a
thousand thousand they just need a major
break yep
next up a little potential casting news
when it comes to the Real Housewives of
Beverly Hills I think I might have heard
this one Paul Abdul says she's been
joined asked to join Real Housewives
many many times no way so Paul Abdul
revealed to page six that she's been
approached repeatedly by Bravo and she
didn't necessarily shut down the
possibility about conceding she said
I've been asked many many times she was
actually asked by Page Six on a red
carpet for the homeless not Toothless
Hollywood gala where cameras were
rolling for the 13th season of Beverly
Hills housewives all the ladies were
there and Paula Abdul was like a guest
of honor I die for Paul Abdul I love her
so much so the pop star said that the
series was a top Contender but it's not
the only one she's been asked but she
definitely like has a special place in
her heart for Beverly other ones has she
been asked I don't know maybe New York
like other franchises she said some
other franchises too but I'm not going
to tell you which I bet OC is she down
there
maybe she's like a beach house yeah I
could see that I don't think she would
be good with those ladies no no she'd be
terrible solo brow yeah I agree she said
she's friends with a lot of the women
and has been for a long time but she
enjoys being a viewer for now I guess
she said as much as I'm absolutely the
biggest fan and I love watching it's a
lot of drama she said she's no stranger
to the drama you know because she was on
American Idol right yada yada
um
and now we have pictures of her you know
she's friends with Kathy Hilton she runs
in a fabulous Circle I'm sure a lot of
the women know her especially after her
charity work with homeless not Toothless
um
the dumbest name for every charity ever
ever she is probably friends with dorit
and Kyle yep I love that that they're
filming at the homeless not Toothless
Gala I love that it's now become like a
stable I know of the brand because I
remember thinking like this is a nice
concept but what a dumb name the worst
name ever and queen Kathy Hilton who
couldn't say it right calling a
toothless not homeless or a toothless
and homeless finally it was like the
elephant in the room nobody wanted to
say it because it's like disrespectful
to like talk about a charity but like
it's stupid it's moronic but I guess in
like a branding sort of way now it's
genius kind of iconic exactly and um I
guess a lot of people did like Research
into the charity after their stint on
housewives and they have like a grade
like they grade the financials of a lot
of
um big time and they have like an F oh
yeah I don't know if it's like the most
ethical organization oh my God wait
Paula I adore yeah I interviewed her I'm
serious oh what was she like I feel like
she's a lot of energy I played this game
and I think okay my mom called me the
other day and she was like I want you to
bring this game back everybody on Tick
Tock okay you'll tell me the truth of my
mom's being ridiculous so it's called
name that Tate tune this is a legit game
we used to play on Sirius on the show
okay where I would like sing songs like
pop songs but I don't know the words to
anything oh okay so I just make them up
so basically it's like gibberish singing
and so people would have to guess the
song I was trying to sing like can you
do one for me like okay I'm trying to
think of like a song um okay so like you
know how Zendaya just performed a
Coachella yeah she did like that amazing
song you know it goes like oh
you know that's how it goes outside
and guess like do one don't tell me what
it is and I'll try and guess what song
it is okay
um think of like a song that's popular
right now okay so I'm gonna do okay wait
tell me what it is I don't know any
popular songs right now oh my god well
then how are you gonna do today Tunes
but like I used to do hey I'm gonna do
what I used to do it's like old okay
that's fine it's a deep track okay okay
honey potato
and the piss off a peso
I've quite literally no idea Lips of an
Angel with the lips actually hear it now
you know I think it could be I think it
could be good on the talk then your
mom's not entirely wrong okay so Paula
came in oh yeah and we did a name that
tattoo tune of her catalog exclusively
and she had to guess the songs I was
singing and she
loved it more than anything in the world
she was dying laughing okay and it made
me fall in love with her I might be like
really out of pocket here but like
what's a Paula Abdul song oh my god well
I'm gonna sing it for real or want me to
sing it she's a cold-hearted snake oh
looked into his eyes for real give me
another one um
Do Do You Love Me Do Do You Love Me Baby
straight up now tell me my first and and
really only sort of interaction with
Paula Abdul I'm dead was American Idol
when I was a kid and I knew that she was
like an old singer I don't know a single
one of her songs oh my God she has the
best songs ever
yeah well she was her lead choreographer
for like ever and ever and ever oh when
is that how she got famous yes exactly
and then she started singing yeah but
she like could like sing on the side wow
yeah Paul's a queen I I don't think I
need her on Real Housewives of Beverly
Hills though because you don't want her
to be like ruined not only that but like
she is at a place where she's still very
much a star and an icon and she has like
a legacy to protect and people like that
who go on go on the show and they don't
give much and she's kooky so I feel like
they could really take that and do like
tarnish a reputation yeah and she won't
do get in the mud
because she has too much to use you're
right you're right like somebody like
who has a recognizable name but doesn't
have a lot to lose is a great addition
to a Housewives franchise because they
need to get back on top Denise Richards
is allegedly coming back as a friend I
know I mean now that now that Lisa's
gone it's like a safe space for her
right I loved Denise and I wish she
fought harder she just kind of conceded
and gave in because she was not in the
mood to do this I do think it was all
true though
for sure my point was never is it true
or not it was that it's nobody's
business she basically outed two women
which is really very unethical yeah it's
taught me a lot about ethics today I
know look at that same ethical Queens
all right speaking of our fifth and
final story well that wasn't a segue I
don't know how I'm gonna segue it but
um Patti LuPone is attacking another
woman again she's like always in the
news for attacking another woman stop
kind of pissing me off okay so she's
slamming Kim Kardashian now for being
cast in American Horror Story yes so she
went on Watch What Happens live on
Sunday and Andy Cohen asked her um if
she gives a damn about Kim Kardashian
being cast in the American Horror Story
horror story franchise she said yes I do
Andy said you don't like it do you she
said no I don't why she's taking a roll
away from actors
excuse this is what her words not mine
excuse me excuse me Kim you know what
you're doing with your life don't get on
that stage Miss Worthington which is
apparently a reference to an English
playwright whatever
she said um Kim is among the biggest and
brightest tele oh no sorry
that's what Ryan Murphy had said that
she's uh they created this role for her
she's the biggest brightest television
star and they're so excited to welcome
her and Patti LuPone when I watch
Robin's live and said she's taking a
role away she shouldn't be on the stage
the screen she doesn't know what she's
doing
here's the thing
the energy is not nice and I don't like
it and the delivery was not well done
but I do kind of I can see and
understand and agree with like this
mentality of like
I feel like the acting world every
actually Avenue in the attention
Ministry is getting saturated with like
a lot of these people who are famous for
not necessarily having like a skill set
and they make a lot of money doing that
so that's what Jackie and I were always
saying is like when it comes to uh you
know entertainment journalism yes
that's not really a job anymore because
it's actors and models who do you know
Laverne Cox Vanessa Hudgens they're
doing red carpets it's not right the
entertainment journalists of your
Juliana Rancic Ryan Seacrest Kat Sadler
Jason Kennedy people who were famous for
being for that job yes so it's not just
acting it's it's a trend in all Fields
yes so for Patti LuPone to and by the
way this is like not the first time
Patti LuPone has attacked another woman
so
she notoriously made fun of Madonna yep
um for
her role of uh
Ava Peron in Evita when it was made into
a film she also
criticized Uma Thurman for her Broadway
performance saying I don't necessarily
need to see film actors on stage because
they can't not in my country they can
can I just say Uma Thurman and the
Parisian women did anybody see it holy
[__] I'm sorry oh she's looking she's a
she's kind of like a vicious like wench
like and always going after other women
she's miserable and jealous there's a
conversation to be had for sure about
like reality stars doing acting and then
influencers doing journalism there's a
conversation to be had it's happening
you know influencers are now boxers like
it's happening in every single field
right there's a lot of cross-pollination
so we can have a conversation about how
you know certain
careers are being depleted we can have a
conversation about that but for patio
opponent it just seems like a trend
where she's like kind of threatened by
other people a thousand percent because
Patti LuPone was in American Horror
Crime Story she was in one of them
uh-huh so she's just like constantly
going after other women and it's giving
like victim energy I really don't like
this yeah I don't like it either she's
clearly like not in a good place in her
career she's not happy with the way
things are going and she's lashing out
because she's jealous and miserable and
she's like a legendary Broadway Queen
like she has a she has a beautiful
Legacy like this is what she's going to
be known for for like just attacking
other people I know you know what's
interesting though it makes me go like
wow she must really like be in Dire
Straits financially because what else
would drive you to be so bitter
constantly yeah and then it's like well
there's something wrong with that too
yeah like you know like let us pay our
theater actors yeah because there is an
issue with this yeah no theater actors
don't get paid nearly enough for how
much work that they do like eight shows
a week yeah I recently was uh
privy to some information about somebody
who does a brilliant job in that space
and what they get paid is a goddamn sin
I know so maybe this is less about Patty
LuPone hating women and more about her
like hating the theater industry well I
will say like when people like Patti
LuPone and other you know actual big
name stars then go to Broadway or either
go back to Broadway they're not getting
paid what Broadway actors are getting
paid they're getting paid what they're
due as a celebrity like Jessica Chastain
is now in the doll's house when you have
like a name you get paid
paid but the other actors don't I bet
Paddy's worth way less than we would
ever think I agree yeah she's remained
pretty loyal to the theater and she's
very bitter she's very bitter yep and
she's and I just feel like these days
like people who like are gonna attack
him there's things you you want to
disagree with the Kardashians on and you
can have a worthy conversation about
Balenciaga sure but like this is just
like such a low blow but it's like
everyone does this and it's like yeah I
don't know it's just like so unoriginal
well the thing is too Patty you're a
star like you get it on Tick Tock yeah
like you're fabulous yeah you would
Thrive so like she's kind of refusing to
evolve so she should get into this space
that she's not in where she's mad that
people are coming into her space that's
really the fix that's the best way to
get revenge yes Patty I don't think
Patty's gonna take any of our advice
zero zetto she toaster
not even close
Taylor I love having you on the toast I
love coming on the toes if you guys
enjoy Taylor make sure to listen to her
podcast a deer media production Taste of
Taylor available wherever you get your
podcast and she also does a Daily Show
much like the toast every single day
Monday through Friday on patreon called
the Taylor's Trekker show and that's
patreon.com the Taylor Striker show uh
I'm sure you'll be back in the coming
weeks amen I mean I'm on tour like crazy
the month of May where are you going
this weekend this weekend is Cleveland
Thursday Indianapolis on Friday and
Saturday is a Milwaukee Milwaukee's a
gorgeous town and then the following
week we're in Dallas and Austin oh my
God wait I'm in Dallas when are you
there no way may what like fifth sixth
yes on the next week oh shoot and well
that and then you're coming to New York
yes we'll be in New York on May 13th
it's a Saturday but this Show's sold out
no I thought it was May 12th
Boston's the 13th Mother's Day the 14th
sorry okay because I moved my flight I'm
like that you made me move my life no no
300 change
that's our show Taylor thank you so much
being here toasters thank you so much
for listening to The Chosen London
Morning Show where we deliver the fast
five stories you need to show everybody
the Friday on YouTube for watching this
on YouTube please don't forget to
subscribe and give this video a thumbs
up we're also available podcast
Republic
star review about a beautiful standing
and wickedly talented we are hope you
guys have an amazing day and we'll see
you oh tomorrow we are in studio with
Sophia Franklin host of Sophia with an F
Podcast Thursday Jackie is joining me
for an audio only episode we'll get an
update from Jax she has been hearing
from you she loves you she is okay and
then Friday I'm gonna be at stagecoach
with Shannon Ford so I mean Shannon Ford
are going to be podcasting live from
Palm Springs that is Audio Only but
we've got a great second half of the
week you don't want to miss it love you
dearly bye